they came full of Hope expecting the
Supreme Court to rule in their favor and
against the powerful Farm Lobby that
wants to limit their constitutional
right to ancestral territories
the justices had to decide whether all
indigenous land claims are valid or only
those made by tribes that were living in
their territories before 1988 when
Brazil's current constitution was
ratified
the 1988 constitution does not establish
a time frame if the Supreme Court votes
in favor of one it would cancel hundreds
of claims which are waiting for a
decision to be made and could even anal
demarcations that have already been made
but the day ended without a ruling one
Supreme Court Justice asked for more
time to make his decision
we're disappointed and very worried
while we're waiting for decision miners
loggers and farmers are having more time
to take over our territories more Bloods
being spilled in land disputes it's
dangerous for us all
Brazil's indigenous population is now
facing yet another challenge the
powerful Farm Lobby and Congress which
is dominated by the conservative caucus
are pushing for legislation that will
open up indigenous territories to
commercial activities like mining
logging and farming the House of
Representatives has already approved a
bill that establishes a time frame for
indigenous land claims the Senate has
put that legislation on Fast Track and
is set to vote on it soon although the
Supreme Court has the final word
conservative congressmen believe they
should be the ones to decide I think
regardless of the decision of the the
Supreme Court it's important
um to have everything else that has to
do with indigenous lands passing through
Congress or through
bills proposed by the executive branch
that indigenous leaders and activists
say they've waited far too long to have
their rights recognized hundreds of land
claims are on hold and a lack of a
decision will only increase the violence
in disputed territories
al-jazeera Brasilia